[Music]
Alexandra SE thank you so much for
joining me H in this miniseries startup
Nation United U you're talking from
France the work that you're doing with
an amazing group of people is really
really inspiring for many many reasons
um I know some of them very well they're
close friends and you and what's very
very incredible
the speed at which you've put this
together the impact this has already
made with hundreds of thousands of of
dollars raised and the deployment of Aid
into really effective meaningful impact
in the ecosystem I think is remarkable
and and I'm excited to tell the story of
of what what it is that you're doing
with standing behind our people
phenomenal names so Alexander thank you
again for joining me tell me a little
bit about yourself you know outside the
context of the of this conflict and the
war what what who are you and and what
do you
do um so I'm Alexandra I'm um originally
live French as you can hear from my
accent I moved to Israel 12 years ago I
made theah and I got married there I'm a
proud mother of three kids and and in
life I'm a tech entrepreneur so
my last Venture was called bit shake and
we sold it like two years ago um and I'm
a convinced Zionist and a very very
proud Jew and probably that's the thing
that defines me the most in all of the
things um I've told
you incredible I I love that that's uh
that's really beautiful and obviously um
the transitioning to October 7th morning
um C caught all of us in different
capaces in different times where did
this catch
you we no one has words okay everyone's
in shock well what I'm telling everyone
is that usually when you speak to the to
Israelis and you ask them how they're
doing they always
say will be fine first time that I'm
speaking to people and they're they're
not answering the question so the pain
is huge
um contrary to you my I moved to Israel
12 years ago the first war operation I
lived was suan in
2014 and and I was very very affected by
this war because you know I came to
Israel I was living freely in this land
I didn't serve in the Army and suddenly
I was seeing soldiers being killed to
protect my right of living freely as a
Jew in Israel um and and then I launched
an initiative as well there are crowd
initiative so it C at the time my Zion
Soul okay but on the 7th of October
things were different and it what what
hurt was not only my Zionist Soul it was
my soul as a Jew my soul as a mother my
soul as a wife my soul as a woman um and
I was on vacation with my family and we
just you know turn down the the open our
phones in the morning so what happened
and and with decided to act we we we we
say that you know something had to be
done um to help because we felt so sad
and and the pain is very intense and and
we felt a bit helpless um especially you
know when you're in Greece you're not
even in Israel people around you don't
understand what you're what's going on
and and the only comfort you can find is
with the Israelis that are there
so tell me about this um impulse
um intuition and urge to help and to be
proactive and to take action it's been
coming up over this over this series
quite quite frequently and I'm
particularly inspired by that intuition
where does that stem from what does that
mean for
you so I tell you it started nine years
ago in suan and the urge was the fact
that I didn't do anything for this
country and I needed to be useful okay
this time it was a mix of if I'm not
doing anything I'm going to be crazy
because I'm all day long on my phone I'm
seeing like terrific uh things I'm I'm
hearing horrific stories and I need to
be in action and the second thing was
you know everyone in Israel every Jew
was acting and we wanted to be part of
it like we know that we can bring a lot
and we wanted to be part of the efforts
and support and try to bring
some relief or at least some help to all
of the victims of this barbaric
Massacre wow okay and you know October
7th hits um and you know you're going to
take action the the formation of
standing behind our people what was that
how did that transpire how did you get
together how did you decide to do this
and operationally what actually happened
how did you do
it so we
I took the learnings of the crowdfunding
campaigns I did for suan where we raised
$200,000 and I had a couple of Dos and
don't okay the do was Act Fast get some
virality okay there's a momentum you can
get a lot of donation and show the
doners immediately the impact of what
they're doing because when people know
where the money is going they donate
more and this is what's creating the
verality so that was for the do the
don't was don't rely on any external
crowdfunding website okay B because it's
very difficult to use the money there is
a lot of admin stuff to do and you don't
have time for that when you work in
chaos and don't work alone okay you need
a team you need to be structured and you
need to make build an organization very
fast so what happened is that when I
decided to take this initiative very
quickly I gathered a couple of friends
okay all of them have a tech background
and so we were six Founders at the time
and we decided to use um a website
builder to build our own website with
our own payment solution within a couple
of hours the website was up and running
someone wrote the content someone built
the ux and and then we started just you
know it took like two three hours to get
things up and running we sent it to
everyone on WhatsApp um Instagram
Facebook and we launched it on Sunday
the 8th of October at 11 p.m. Monday
morning we woke up yeah we didn't sleep
but we raised like 15,000 after one day
100,000 and in 10 days it was over
650,000
holy crap that's incredible so you you
managed to get a group of people
together under a unified Mission and set
the the the goals and the messaging and
the positioning set up the technological
infrastructure get it up and running
within I guess about you know 36 hours
from when it actually happened and then
actually get H thousands of dollars in
within the first day of this being
live yeah that was crazy but because the
mobilization was crazy I mean every
single person every single Jew not
person I was talking too was willing to
help in a way everyone wanted to feel
that you know they they could come
contribute to the efforts so the
mobilization was
incredible wow okay and so what tell me
a little bit about this the the
deployment strategy here because I think
that's an important aspect of of what
you're doing this is um this is not a
traditional nonprofit raising money and
then talking for a long time and then
and then deploying it strategically an
important areas but often takes time
here I I saw in in the two- pager you
shared with me that you've deployed 80
to you know youo 80 to 90% of the funds
already with the immediately to
different so tell me a little bit about
that strategy and why you've chosen that
strategy yeah so our shortterm mission
was really to provide concrete and
immediate aid to the victims of the
attacks and to the Israeli soldiers at
the front line okay and if you want to
do that you need to be efficient so we
really built an operation that is
supported by a technology uh not only
the website builder but also a tool that
you particularly cherish that's called
notion okay so we quickly equi ourselves
with the technology um and we built a
process to make sure that we could
become a hub to receive requests from
soldiers from NOS from civilians and to
process those request as quickly and
efficiently as possible okay so what we
did was basically um
to you know a three-step process in
order to make sure that a we are
reviewing and vetting the request we
wanted to make sure that the requests
are legitimate needed and not addressed
okay so we had to verifies for every
request we receive we verifies the
source of the request we verified that
there's an existing need um we go
directly to the source we don't work
with any intermediaries we coordinate
with other major initiatives to source
as much as the request as possible
because as you know there have been a
thousand of initiatives launched and
there are a lot of duplicates so we
really developed a partnership strategy
to make sure that we are sourcing as
many things as possible okay so that's
the first thing the second thing is that
we're prioritizing the request so we
identif ify the most urgent request okay
we don't deal with Comfort request we
deal with urgent request and there are a
lot of requests that are Comfort request
especially from soldiers and we
understand and we want them to be
comfortable but we're working in
emergency we're working in chaos so we
only deal with very urgent requests um
and the last thing is by the way how do
you how do you distinguish I'm sure you
have large volumes how do you
distinguish effectively between the
request
um internally
operationally and in terms of urgent not
urgent or in terms of so urgent not
urgent for every request that we receive
so we have um a template in which we
want to receive the request including a
lot of information that we need to get
beforehand okay if people are not
feeling the template the request doesn't
get matched sorry but we need to work
efficiently so once we get this template
we have a point of contact we have
people calling the point of contact so
we have formed a group of X soldiers
xunit soldiers in different units that
really can understand the need um and
and assess the request okay if someone
is asking for 100 I don't know bags we
make sure that they need 100 and not 20
and most of the time the quantity is not
the same and that they really need it so
we call every single person and then we
review the request and and and we know
if it's urgent not urgent based on that
because we have experts I mean experts
EXO soldiers assessing
it fantastic that's that's phenomenal
and so I'd love to hear a little bit
about the formation of the group and how
you've aligned um you you mentioned
before a few times the importance of
cohesion with the the the core team and
and and and working in a structured way
you can't do this alone you have to do
this as a
team how what did you as a leader do
during this time to to get that to
really to really streamline that process
and to make it effective I think that
the
output of what you've done speaks as a
testament to the success of of this
cohesion of this core team but what how
what was the experience from your end in
building this and and creating
this I think things kind of fall into
place fell into place quite naturally
okay we had very we had a pool of
talents in very different areas and what
we did is that we structured the team
into different departments so I'm you
know managing the project and I'm in
charge of fundraising uh my husband is
in charge of uh partnership and it was
it was also a VB partnership in a
startup and now he's building his own
startup my best friend um who is also an
ex founder she's the head of operation
and she's the queen of processes and
notion um her brother um is also the CEO
of a startup and the Very techsavvy guy
so he's the head of R&D and then we have
a head of logistics and Supply okay who
is also a friend who is taking care of
you know all the suppliers and stuff we
have a head of branding we have a head
of growth uh we have a head of HR a head
of legal so we really try to take the
experti of each and to split it into
different departments and then every
person is and owns their own departments
and recuit recruits volunteers so around
that we have a pool of 50 volunteers
that help us in all kind of different
ways it can go from content writing to
delivering some items from one point to
another and they're very reactive and
they're very involved and and this is
how you know all of this supported by
the technology and this um notion that
we build that very customized to our
needs where we can track centralize all
the requests see exactly where they're
standing centralize all the suppliers
pay the builds and everything just falls
into place and is very organized I think
this is why is making our strength like
we we all we we we're a product of the
startup Nation because we are all you
know Tech
entrepreneurs and and and as startup
Founders we've acquired extensive
knowledge in working in cows in working
in a fast-paced and rapidly growing
environments in adapting and pivoting
very quickly and most most importantly
in achieving more with less we all know
that we never have enough resources and
we need to achieve a lot and I think all
of these things just you know were put
together and and contributed to to the
success of the
campaign Alexandra this is so inspiring
and awesome really what you've done in
such a short amount of time both as a as
on firstly on the impact itself and um
the fact that you've been making such an
extraordinary impact um tangibly just
you know from from the very practical
perspective that's one but then being
able to do it so quickly that's another
element and doing it with so many
amazing people so many amazing
volunteers and you've articulated a few
times the importance of doing this in a
structured process that you're
particularly proud of and then tying
that together into the startup nation
and and the fact that we're all United
and I'm going back to the very beginning
of our conversation where you talked
about your
personal sense of urgency to to take
action and to not be a bystander and to
make and to make an impact yourself so
Alexandra thank you so much for all the
amazing work that you do um you know
it's October 24th now at the time of
recording this so we're about I guess um
17 days after uh after this whole thing
started and uh and it's uh and it's just
crazy so thank you very very much for
everything and then I'm wishing you best
of luck and continue making a great
impact and inspiring us thank you so
much Michael have a nice
[Laughter]
day